this morning I've written a letter to
Graham Brady the chairman of the 1922
committee and I would like to read it
out to you the best interest of our
country inspired me to stand for the
leadership I believe that in leaving the
EU a bright future awaits where all our
people can share in a new prosperity
freedom and democracy the referendum
results demonstrated a clear desire for
change strong leadership is needed
urgently to begin the work of
withdrawing from the European Union a
nine-week leadership campaign at such a
critical moment for our country is
highly undesirable business needs
certainty as a strong and unified
government must move quickly to set out
what an independent United Kingdom's
framework for business looks like it is
also essential that current EU workers
in the UK and the businesses that employ
them know where they stand the
Conservative Party was elected only last
year with a strong manifesto
we now need a new prime minister in
place as soon as possible
committed to fulfilling that manifesto
as well as implementing the clear
instructions from the referendum Teresa
made carries over 60% of support from
the parliamentary party she is ideally
placed to implement brexit on the best
possible terms for the British people
and she has promised that she will do so
for me personally to have won the
support of 84 of my colleagues last
Thursday was a great expression of
confidence for which I am incredibly
grateful nevertheless this is less than
25% of the parliamentary party and after
careful consideration I do not believe
this is sufficient support to
need a strong and stable government
should I win the leadership election
there is no greater privilege than to
lead the Conservative Party in
government and I would have been deeply
honored to do it I have however
concluded that the interests of our
country are best served by the immediate
appointment of a strong and well
supported Prime Minister I am therefore
withdrawing from the leadership election
and I wish to resume the very greatest
success
I assure her of my full support here
thank you very much